point out a couple of things with
respect to Ramadan, with respect to
what's past, and with respect to
tomorrow Eid and what is to come and to
follow.
We all hear hope.
Hope that Allah has accepted from us our
fasting, has accepted from us our
prayer, has accepted from us any effort
that we put in, no matter how great or
small it is. However,
what comes with that hope is a desire to
know, has Allah actually accepted from
us? And the question is, does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tell us when he
accepts something from us?
In other words, does he interact with us
or is it just a blind kind of thing?
We're just seeing what sticks and just
trying all things and we can never
really know because Allah doesn't really
respond.
How do we know if Allah accepted
something from us? Who can tell us?
[Arabic recitation]
longer there. He said, "By our
pretty pretty clear. I don't think it
could be written in any broader ink
that your actions increase, your good
deeds increase. Right? So we all have
the right idea. Listen to this verse of
the Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
"Is there any
adequate reward for good
than more good?"
Notice that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
has promised us that he will reward us
and that reward is predicated on the
idea that he has accepted something from
us and he asked this rhetorical question
here and it being in the question form
is even more emphatic than it being a
statement. So notice Allah doesn't say
in this verse the reward for goodness is
more good. He doesn't say it that.
He says is there any other reward
appropriate for good than good?
And the reason it comes in a question is
as if to say this is absolutely logical.
This is no other no logic would ever
lead to any other conclusion. Everyone
knows this. Anyone who has his sanity
intact knows that there is no recompense
appropriate for the best than that which
is the best.
And he doesn't say alass. He says and
in the Arabic language means
is perfecting something working to
perfect something.
So we understand from this verse
that when we do something good
the indication indication that Allah has
accepted it from us is that that good
becomes better.
that not only do we retain that good but
it becomes what better.
Listen to this narration
in Mus Ahmed. The prophet sallall.ai
tells us
he says Allah gives worldly wealth to
those whom he loves and those whom he
does not love. But he only gives eman to
those whom he loves. What is eman? Is it
just belief? Are deeds part of eman?
So all good.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to it
as e all good deeds.
So I get it right. So who was correcting
me?
You're making me double double doubt
myself. Okay. So
the point here is that iman is not just
belief. Eman is belief, action, speech,
giving, refraining from haram. All of
this is eman.
And so paradise is for the
those who do. It's not just my heart is
good, but my actions are bad. That
doesn't exist. Whatever's in here
manifests in here, out here. That's how
it works.
And so if you want to know if your was
accepted,
watch yourself after Ramadan.
If you want to know if your fasting was
accepted, watch yourself after
Ramadan. If you want to know if your
charity was accepted, watch yourself
after Ramadan.
The hypocrites came and repented. Oh,
we're so sorry.
But what was the response?
He said the real test to see if someone
has repented or not is do continue
leading continue doing and Allah and his
messenger and the believers will observe
your future actions. That's the
indicator. And that is the secret why
the companions were so
earnest with doing good deeds. Many of
the companions were told they would be
in paradise. The 10 that were giving
glad tidings of paradise and many others
there they're over 20 that were told you
will be in paradise. You will be in
paradise. That's a side of groups that
were actually told all of the
people of Badr, all of the people of
Bewan,
right?
All of them were told that they would be
in paradise. But when we watch their
actions, after they were told they would
be in paradise, their actions increased.
Why? because they know that if Allah
wants you in paradise, he's going to
give you the paradise that comes that is
in here first.
Allah says,
"Indeed, the righteous are currently
right now in a state of bliss
because as the scholars tell us, there
is a Jenna in this earth, a paradise in
this earth that exists.
You will not enter paradise in the next
unless you have entered the paradise
that is here on this earth first. What
is that paradise?
The remembrance of Allah, the obedience
of Allah. That is the paradise on earth.
If you enter it, you will enter the
paradise of the hereafter. If you have
been prohibited and barred from entering
it, most likely you will be prohibited
and barred from the paradise of the
hereafter. So if you look at things like
this, you understand that Ramadan is
actually the finish line. Have we
reached the finish line or have we
reached the starting line? We actually
have just reached the starting line. We
didn't reach the finish line. If you
want your
to be accepted, continue your now. If
you want your fasting to be accepted,
continue your fasting after. If you want
your charity to be accepted, continue
your charity after. If you want your
attendance to the masid in the house of
Allah to be accepted, continue your
attendance to the house of Allah after
Ramadan. Because Ramadan, the God of
Ramadan is the God of the other 11
months. And Allah reminds us,
he tells us the number of months with
Allah are 12. He is to be worshiped in
all 12. If you can retain what you
accomplish this Ramadan, imagine what
you will do next Ramadan and the Ramadan
after and the Ramadan after. Imagine
where we can go individuals and
collective where we are headed if this
is the attitude that we foster. But if
the attitude we foster is, you know,
Ramadan's over, back to business as
usual, we're just going to keep taking
one step forward and two steps
backwards. And honestly, I am very
pleasantly surprised tonight because I
thought there'd be two or three guys
here tonight. I didn't think anybody was
going to show up. Not because I'm being
pessimistic or because I'm being
negative. It's just what I've seen
in my experience, right? But it would
appear to me that we are making
progress together. We're all making
progress together, right? We are not
strangers to each other. If you go
missing tomorrow, I am going to go
looking for you. If I go missing
tomorrow, you are going to go looking
for me. We need to be so tightly knit
that none of us is going to suffer in
silence anymore. Never again.
That I should feel ashamed of myself if
my brother is suffering and he is forced
to come and ask me for help. The
companions would be very distraught with
themselves if someone asked them, one of
their brothers asked them for something.
You know why they would say, "I should
have known. Why did I force my brother
to have to swallow his pride and to
humiliate himself to come and ask me? I
should have known. I should have been a
better brother. I should have been a
better sister." And we can do that. We
have these illusions in our mind that
oh, you know, we're not overseas. We're
not in a Muslim country. And we're not
the companions. And you know, any little
thing we do is good enough. And you
know, alhamdulillah, for people in
America in this day and age, we're doing
pretty good. We're not doing good
enough. We're not. And we can do a lot
better. So, let's go there. Let's break
that cycle. Let's go better because
that's the only way that our children
are going to become better. Now the
next thing that we want to mention is
with respect to Eid tomorrow we have a
couple of rules and our you know this is
what separates us from the from the from
the animal world is we have rules right
so number one
we're going to have security and we're
going to have volunteers it's a big
effort it's a monumental effort it is
mostly headed by Ahmed J 99.9 9% of it
and he has worked his fingers to the
bone, mashallah, in his time with us
during this Ramadan. Honestly, he's our
elder and we couldn't thank him
enough for his help. But these
volunteers, these security, me, the
board, everyone that is here trying to
help enforce these rules, we're here
to help you. So, you have to help us
help you. So follow the rules. If the
security guard says don't park here,
park over here, don't question. Don't
say why. I need to know why. Explain it
to me right now. That is a very bad
soldier. You are soldiers now. Take
command. The best of soldiers isn't the
strongest. It isn't the fastest. It
isn't the most skilled. It's the one who
embraces being a soldier and takes
command, right? is able to take to take
directions. Okay. Number two, if you
have a child with you under the age of
10,
please head to the gym. This area, so
the malah here, the main mosa upstairs
and downstairs, we're not going to want
any children that are under the age of
10 in here. Okay? There's a number of
reasons. is one of them is is peace and
quiet. It's a happy day. You can't
expect them to sit perfectly still,
right? It's just it's unnatural. If a
child is very still and very quiet,
something is wrong. That's not a a child
that is healthy, right? So, if you have
children with you under the age of 10,
take them to the gym. You will get the
same experience in the gym. We have the
microphone hooked up. We have everything
there. You'll be able You're right
there. So, just go to the gym. ,
usually we have food, drinks, candy,
stuff that, and it becomes a
disaster place in here. It It comes to a
point where your feet are sticky, you're
walking on stuff, kids are going to
spill stuff.
So, any child under 10, we want them to
be chaperoned in the gym, please. Number
two, wear your best clothing. This is
the time of year for the best of
clothing. Number three, salah is at
9:00, so come as early as you can to
give time to be able to park. Obviously,
there'll be a lot of traffic and so
forth. Number four,
you are not required to listen to the
hutba. You don't have to. You don't have
to. If you want to, fine. I'll be given
the hutba. It'll be about 10 minutes
long. That is better. But you don't have
to listen. But if you don't want to
listen and you want to chat or catch up
or whatever, you have to leave to do
that. So you either stay to listen to
the hutba or you leave to the outside to
talk or whatever it is. Don't stay in
here because
it'll be hard for those who do want to
listen to be able to listen. Salah
is two and the first
after
making the first Allahbar to start the
salah will have seven additional
you just say Allahbar with the im then
you listen to the recitation in the
second it is five additional
and I'll mention this again tomorrow but
prepare your families for that and the
final thing that we want to mention is
to make sure that you get your zakat
taken care of and squared away before
it is obligatory. It is referred to as
zaka because it is of the same
importance and obligation as as regular
zaka and it is a part of your fasting.
Meaning that your fasting is incomplete
until you give zakat. Then it puts that
final nail in in in that in that frame.
So make sure that you get your zakat
squared away before salah. After salah
zakut is cut off and you cannot give it.
That's it. It's it's over at that point.
So make sure that you give zakat before
you do that. And then you know keep
coming for all of the salah and so
forth. And
Subhanahu
Yes, we have a question here.
[Arabic recitation]
Right. Usually from what I understand
it's usually the community there from
from Abu Hanifa center right if you want
to make that salah that's fine there's
no problem with that but we I will be
given at 9:00 yes rules
[Arabic recitation]
mean same same sheriff here for for
both of them so let's go ahead and
and keep that in order when someone
disrespects our rules anyone one.
They're disrespecting all of us. They're
telling us you and your rules are
beneath me. No one is beneath our rules.
No one. Not me, not the board, not
anyone. So, do not allow anyone to
disrespect you. We have to in order to
harvest our our you know in order to to
better advance ourselves and to raise
ourselves all of us for Allah to raise
us we have to enforce our rules and
respect our rules right so that's what
it's there for it's not just for us to
talk down to people it's so that
everyone is able to come and receive
their full measure here at the masid
that they are allotted
is at 5:45 inshallah.
[Silence]
Yeah,
first
[Silence]
Hello.
Love you.
[Silence]
Hello.
Yeah.
in
[Silence]
it.
You know what?
[Silence]
What was
I'm going
[Silence]
Memphis.
Yeah.
Well,
[Silence]
Happy
speech.
Come
[Silence]
on.
Give us
[Silence]
No.
Oh my god.